[Music]
southland is a terrific show uh
congratulations on that but i'm curious
do you still get fans of the oc that
come up to you and want to talk to you
about the oc or your character on the oc
thank you thank you you know uh it's
funny so on southland we use real gang
members to play our
our gangs our gang guys so x
sort of right so uh we're doing uh this
is very beginning of the show one
episode is aired and um
uh some of these guys were on break and
there's this big guy like 6'2 about 220.
he's um mexican-american he's got
tattoos all over his head shaved head
tattoos everywhere
and he turns to me in the break and he
says uh
amon
i like your work
and you know southland has aired one
episode so i'm not exactly sure what
he's referring to so i say oh thank you
and he says yeah yeah man
the o.c
he used to watch that [ __ ] in the joint
he would watch the oc in prison in
prison yeah and i said
really oh yeah man thursday night nine
o'clock all down the cell block you hear
california
thinking of those guys getting lost in
the love truck yeah yeah yeah marissa oh
i hope she's all right yeah yeah yeah
uh that's nice though you'll always have
those you know if you need as many fans
as you can get i hope you're not too
passionate about their fandom yeah
because they're pretty scary guys i can
imagine uh now you're you take your
acting seriously which shows in your
work but you i've learned have a little
bit of
where you're pulling that from no it's
true i think you are i think of you as a
serious actor but but you have i've
learned an unorthodox way of working
right a little bit right i'm sure good
actors would tell you that acting is all
about listening right
i believe it's about learning your lines
um and so i use my dog
i i have a dog he's a pit he's very sort
of deadpan right and um
and he's very useful because you really
need just to learn your lines you don't
need
anyone to actually say what because who
cares right right right
you need to just say when your time
comes spout out your exactly and so this
dog very patient his default look is
kind of like go aft yourself that's kind
of his what his right he's like or
you're crazy that kind of like
what are you doing kind of right and uh
so we sit and we're on lines and he's
great i mean he's very patient
um
and uh that's how that works does it i'm
just curious does it does anyone ever
come by and see you i mean you're never
out with your dog in the park and people
see you saying things like you're going
down yeah yeah you're going down yeah
yeah yeah menendez you're going down i'm
gonna get you
yeah exactly exactly now i'm told you uh
went to japan i didn't too long ago i
did i've never been you gotta i mean oh
you're never i've never been to japan
it's wonderful you would be fascinating
over there they would be fascinated by
you
thanks a lot i guess i'm a freak no
not you're hey elephant
you've got to tour the countryside of
england anybody who's blonde-haired and
blue-eyed right and you're you know
fairly tall gentlemen yes they would uh
they look at you like you know you're
interesting to them right yeah
fascinating when i was a kid my dad took
me uh he's a research doctor and he took
me on this trip in south america and i
had bright orange hair yeah freckles
like my two front teeth were dead and i
had a multi-colored madras jacket
sportsco ugliest thing you've ever seen
and he took me through south america
like visiting these hospitals and stuff
and i would walk around people would
just i was like a traveling yes clown
yes i was a traveling clown not much has
changed really
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding we're
done oh we are so done
you're so good
even when you even when you get home
your dog's going to be like
do it again
not cool